we have a tweet from Elon Musk he says
at this point there is no question that
this Administration is actively
facilitating illegal immigration the
numbers speak for themselves let me just
say that one more time Elon Musk says
Joe Biden is facilitating illegal
immigration let me one up that for you
Elon the Biden Administration is
actively colluding with human
traffickers that's a fact they've been
doing it for years there's multiple news
reports loading children they're
smuggling children they're trafficking
children on planes in uh in in the dead
of night there's videos of this and you
can look at all the statements from
politicians it's been a story for five
years now take a look at this graph by
all available metrics this
administration's border policy is a
disaster take a look at this under Trump
there was a major spike in encounters
and we know this because that's when we
got the Caravans Trump went nuts then we
see a massive decline to the lowest
level we've SE in a long time because
Trump said we're going to shut this down
as soon as Joe Biden's elected he opened
the doors just take a look at the
numbers they speak for themselves we
have unprecedented illegal immigration
and right now the Biden Administration
is suing Texas attempting to do
everything in their power to stop the
border states from putting an end to the
Invasion the incursion of 10,000 plus
people per day at the southern border
this is sedition against the United
States it is a VI a direct violation of
the Constitution and I will say this
I've said it several times the only
reason it happens is because there are
people in law enforcement who say to
themselves I know it's wrong but I've
got to feed my
kids that is that is the argument made
by every corrupt individual who
exemplifies evil they cut a deal with
the devil to save their families and I
totally understand why they would
because they want to make sure their
kids have full bellies and they took the
deal with the devil figuratively or L
literally however you want to see it to
sell out and destroy this country for
themselves for their short-term gains
the only thing is those kids will
inherit a pile of Embers because of what
they've done
yeah I mean this is a really interesting
argument because if you work for you
know Customs or and trol if you're
working at a federal level theoretically
Texas is really trying to do the
opposite right Texas is trying to
enforce border law so you could maybe
leave your job for a state level
position and still get to work in your
chosen field and also have a governor
who is willing to back you there are
ways that especially with the border
that you don't have to be necessarily
supporting the Biden Administration who
is trying to undermine all immigration
laws that are on books I just got to get
a little biblical with it and I'll say
this again let's if you are an atheist
by all means you're allowed to be I'm
not a Christian um take this all as
metaphor uh take it figuratively if you
are religious take it literally when we
had the guys from Angel Studios talking
about the film The Shift where the
benefactor transports a guy to a reality
without his family and he says I'll give
you everything back I'll give you
everything you've ever dreamed of just
serve me and instead the man begins to
pray and refuses uses to serve what is
figuratively the devil and I believe
they said it was it was it was
effectively like the story of job you
know and I I'm not it's been a really
long time since I I studied these
stories but no matter how bad things got
he would never just give in and and take
the assistence of the of the of the
devil so this this is what I see
figuratively literally however you want
to cut it there are federal law
enforcement agents that are actively
working against the local residents in
law enforcement of Texas to stop them
from protecting their homes and these
people are doing it and I would say full
well they know what they're doing is
evil but they're saying to themselves
yeah but if I leave this job my kids
won't have food because we hear it all
the time it's true your kids won't have
food so as you are in service of
darkness and evil and cutting that deal
with the devil you know I certainly
understand why you did it not like
anyone's gonna forgive you
though no I mean I think especially with
the border crisis as bad as it is I
wonder if Democrats look themselves and
say I'm gonna vote for Joe Biden even
though that's a vote to continue human
trafficking across the border right it's
a vote to
continue drug trafficking that issue
they consider it
last up until now they'll say all the
time you know human trafficking is bad
and this is awful and whatever else
except when it's on their doorstep and
they could theoretically do something
about it I mean I can understand where
if you've been told shutting the Border
makes you racist else why they're afraid
of it but that's what they should think
of it as that those are the real world
consequences you know a lot of
Republicans talk about the the drug
trafficking across the border which is
obviously awful it affects a lot of
Americans the obod crisis is uh you know
just a complete assault on our nation on
the other hand if that argument won't do
if you don't care what happens to
Americans why don't you care what
happens to young children and women who
are trafficked across the border like at
what point do you recognize that you are
advocating for a international violation
of any kind of human decency and instead
they're like no it's bad we got to keep
the Border open it's great I mean this
is the thing this is my favorite topic
actually talk about with people who are
left leaning because it's like a lot of
people who would vote Democrat are
bleeding hearts right they believe that
they're trying to help people and if
you're able to say these policies harm
people they are more likely to be open
to them I think the border is the border
is a crazy issue because there were so
many Republicans who like would not talk
about it they were afraid to be called
racist they afraid to do whatever I mean
the Republican house I think or congress
wouldn't necessarily they they fought
giving Trump funding for the border wall
when he was in office because they were
like well it's not that big prior a shut
down for that right and look at us now
like this is a major issue we are paying
the prices and in fact we had a
president that wanted to intercede
earlier who wanted to stop this and even
if you don't like Trump right don't you
care about human trafficking don't you
care about Neighbors in your communities
dying of drug overdoses like this is the
big Reckoning at the border which is it
was messag it mess me around it was like
if you want to close it you're racist
and the reality is actually it's a huge
it's a hugely compassionate issue to say
we are not going to have this this uh
Finish Line at which point people are
incentivized to send their families to
people who want to traffic and harm them
but are they getting that message
because you have all these organizations
that are saying like they're screaming
the racism yeah so and they there are a
lot of organizations that are built
around encouraging people to cross like
nonprofit organizations that are uh
structured around encouraging
right and so why would you turn off that
cash flow if if the purpose of your
nonprofit is to solve an issue like
trying to get people to cross illegally
puts them out of business if they solve
the problem can you guess how much the
cartel has made in December alone with
the record breaking of 300,000 two
million a day I'm talking about in a day
a day how much they $ 32 million a day
from this it's also an issue of framing
like I think this has a lot to do with
the echo chambers that most people who
follow politics find them themselves in
so you can frame that issue in that way
and it's accurate but sharing the
horrors of what's going on is not going
to be how they receive that information
they're not going to get the information
from somebody who's willing to share all
the facts of what it actually means to
go through a border crossing right not
the coyotes not all of the drugs that
come through it's Being Framed to them
whether it's by MSNBC CNN any of these
places as a humanitarian issue that they
have to be a bleeding heart on so
therefore they don't get the full breath
of what's actually happened which is why
theirs don't
change I I I got an idea I got a I got a
really really great idea uh when these
people come to the border and they
demand Asylum what we do is we get them
a very comfortable bus really nice one
like I'm talking like you ever see those
luxury buses that go from like New York
to DC and they got recliner chairs you
know about the Greyhound they're not
Greyhounds are not comfortable but they
got these really nice ones it's like
super cheap and then they got these big
chairs up top and you got this glass SE
oh this is really great you can see
everything we take yeah me we'll put all
the migrants on there and we'll bring
them to Native American reservations and
then when the left you know advocates
for immigration we'll say absolutely
yeah we'll send them to the Native
American reservations isn't that what's
what's wrong why are you up why are you
upset about aren't they like federally
protected sure so here's the solution
the the reservations are federally
protected ferally recognized Texas is
upset about doesn't want people there
here's a solution the left thinks
migration is a good thing so who would
complain if we send these immigrants to
Native American reservation everyone
should be happy right that's true well
this idiot May of M well former idiot
mayor mind cuz I don't live in New York
City anymore he's suing the Texas bus
company so I'm how much damage is that
going to do I I think I think the answer
here is just for Abbott to send the the
migrants to Native American reservations
and then ask the left why they're upset
if they get mad about it they should be
very happy because migration is a good
thing right if you like it so much why
don't you encourage it everywhere it's
it's weird right I mean this we know
what'll happen the left will call him
racist and start attacking him because
it's that's what they're doing if the
migrants come to this country it's a
good thing but you know that if a
governor sent them to a Native American
reservation they'd say how dare you
you're racist blah blah blah I mean look
how fast they cleared out Martha's
Vineyard right there some places that
they are not we we don't like migrants
going to certain places lital the
liberal Banshee shrieking over the
Martha's Vineyard thing was hilarious
the most Nim of nimi there is but
they're more you are yes no I think it's
crazy I mean the other part that bothers
me about this is like where were you
guys back in the day I love that
Republicans have gotten on board I will
be a little bit cynical right now and
say this has been an issue that anyone
could have spotted for a long time and I
just don't understand why people didn't
embrace it sooner I can never understand
that and it was also something that at
least back in the early 2010s and and
earlier that Democrats at least paid lip
service to right they pretended to want
to close the border Clinton in one ofate
of was like let's close the border it's
important Obama mention had like the
most support Chas here in any Democratic
presidency in the last 30 years deporter
and chief right so it's not compl look
at his immigration rate that's like this
is like Biden's biggest accomplishment
it's not the economy or not the stock
market that like you know recuperated
all 2022 losses it's the fact that he's
broken the the migration encounters
every single month and he even decreased
the one month because of title 42 oh he
should get like a Guinness World Record
shouldn't he I know right for for least
secure border under presidency Joe Biden
and you broke every single record even
broke in Bush's record and that it was
not really hard to do there will be
people who are like good more this is a
great idea I mean I think the fact that
they could just walk in and there's no
like you know background check there's
nothing going on had their press
conference the other day there were
migrants crossing in the background and
that's not even the first time that has
happened where there's been a live press
conference Republicans need to stop with
this like lip service and like pull the
strings like stop with this like shenan
is and make it happen in capital but
that's what they were doing with like
when they had that Ukraine funding bill
and they were like okay if you want to
pass this you have to increase border
security and Democrats were like crazy
absolutely not now we don't support
Ukraine also we haven't talked to about
Ukraine in a while I feel like uh it's
just throwback who I just find it funny
like the Senators that are really trying
to get the push the uh immigration and
the Ukraine have the only one is like
Cinema she's only doing this because of
election year for her
then you got a guy from like what Chris
what you got
um Connecticut and then you got um
Langford from
Oklahoma and like they really just
really mostly push it for Ukraine fund
there's nothing really about anything
for the Border cuz they're really not
really talking about it no I mean the
border is something Republicans alone
talk about which is crazy they'll talk
about it but they want to attach to
something can we stop attaching things
to things well right now they're using
it as a tool to stop other things right
because they know Democrats won't give
it on it they the Democrats see
supporting a closed border or even you
know enforcing book laws that are on the
books how dare we as death as as as the
uh you know end of their career so
Republicans are using it to stop things
and I think you're right they should do
things to move it forward unfortunately
I think they believe that the Biden
Administration would veto or stop
anything no because you know why they're
going to Cave the same way how they did
with the whole Deb um the de ceiling we
caved and we added more to the deficit
than we did to try to like you know cut
and
redus I mean it's possible the thing is
Republicans are all lip talk and they
all bark they're like little
Chihuahuas and they think they're like
pit bus and it's just like all right
stop with this lip service and what chip
Roy said is true there's nothing we
could take back home and say that we
accomplish anything thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a member
over at
timcast.net only shows exclusive thanks
for hanging out and we'll see you all
next
time